we have company ABCD trading at $50 a
share let's draw a payoff diagram for a
put option with a $50 strike price
trading at $10 so once again we're going
to draw two types of payoff diagrams one
type that only cares about the value of
the option at expiration and this is
what you tend to see in academic
settings business schools or textbooks
and then the other one will actually
draw the profit and loss up based on
that option position and so it
incorporates the price you actually paid
for the option you tend to see this more
in practice so you have a put option
remember this is the right to sell this
is the right to sell the stock at $50 so
if the stock let's say at expiration so
all of this is at expiration if at
expiration the stock is trading at zero
the company went bankrupt it's now
worthless what is the put option worth
well you would now go on to the market
buy it for pennies or buy it for almost
zero dollars and then you would exercise
your put option and you would sell it
for $50 so you would definitely exercise
and you would make a lot of money if the
underlying stock can be bought for zero
the put option is now worth $50 because
you can buy it for zero and then sell it
for $50 if you have the put option if
the underlying stock price is if the
underlying stock price is ten dollars
then you still could go buy the stock
for ten dollars if you have the option
you would exercise the option to sell it
at 50 so you would make $40 so the
option would be worth $40 anyone who is
holding the option would make an instant
$40 so it goes the value of the option
becomes less and less as the value of
the stock becomes more and more up until
you get to $50 at $50 you wouldn't
really care you could you have the right
to sell something at $50 which you could
buy for $50 so it's kind of worth noting
so the value of the put option it starts
at $50 because you have the right to
sell something that's worthless at $50
if the stock were to go bankrupt then
and then at $50 it becomes the the
option you don't really has it doesn't
have any value any more and if the stock
goes anything above $50 it still is
worthless if the stock is if the stock
is at $100
something like that there's no way you
would exercise the option because why
would you why would you exercise the
right to sell something at 50 we're on
the open market you could sell it at 100
now let's do the same thing for the
profit and loss version so if the stock
is worth nothing you could buy it for
nothing and then if you have the option
sell it for $50 but we have to
incorporate the fact that you paid $10
for the option so instead of saying that
the option is worth 50 we would say it's
worth 50 minus this 10 so it would be
worth $40 and this is all the way you
would exercise the option all the way
until you the option is worth $50 but at
$50 instead of saying it's worthless you
have to remember at 50 if the stock is
$50 you wouldn't exercise the option but
you did pay $10 for it so you wouldn't
exercise something that you paid $10 for
so you would have to take a $10 loss so
the option starts at 50 and becomes
worth less less less and less all the
way to the point that if you don't
exercise it you took the loss of paying
for an option and not exercising it and
then any stock price above that you just
took you just took a $10 loss